bienvenido a france 24 como lo decíamos
es la primera vez que los cancilleres de
ucrania y rusia se reúnen para intentar
encontrar una solución diplomática a la
guerra sin embargo esto ocurre mientras
siguen los combates que tanto puede
servir la negociación es posible lograr
un cese al fuego
en este momento es difícil de seguir
anteriormente hubo la esperanza que la
negociación de hoy en turquía resultaría
un paso prometedor hacia un cese al
fuego o hacia un cese a las hostilidades
totalmente no obstante la retórica de
que escuchamos a partir de las reuniones
especialmente la del uso sugieren que
desafortunadamente aquello que va a
seguir empujando los eventos va a ser la
ofensiva militar llosa y no las
negociaciones de la única esperanza por
el momento es que la puerta del comercio
sigue abierta y tendríamos que esperar
está la siguiente ocasión y que hay un
mayor compromiso de las partes
particularmente la russa
a encontrar una solución inmediata
y mientras llega a una próxima ronda de
negociaciones vimos que tras la reunión
de hoy hubo acusaciones de lado y lado
sobre los bombardeos contra el hospital
en mariupol se puede decir que estos
encuentros sirven más para que los
gobiernos defiendan su versión de los
hechos
por el momento
desafortunadamente eso es lo que está
sucediendo
la metódica de ambas partes nos sugiere
que hay un genuino diálogo más bien es
una ocasión para defender su perspectiva
y
la evidencia de esto está en el hecho
que no ha resultado una ley una
que un
corredor humanitario o un cese al fuego
con acciones humanitarias
la parte rusa en
ocasiones acusado de estos jóvenes
mayores son abusados hoy la parte
ucraniana y al mismo tiempo vemos los
resultados de los ataques rusos y de
sus argumentos al respecto del ataque de
las víctimas civiles de la dukan ya no
gracias por éste